j hat audra pointed out how well he has
done at home his overall record four and
four has given up 16 home runs and the
key for jay because he doesn't
change speeds a lot is that fastball
command nico goodram leading off one and
two and there you go strikeout's a
pretty good way to start tonight eric
haas detroit native
popped up
and sono near the bag again in foul
territory puts it away 11 pitches that
minnesota twins line up facing derek
scuba we all know he's got that real
good high 90s fastball
the one two
popped up
shallow right field
mizara in willie castro calls him off
the base is empty for this guy right
here yeah what a player first pitch
swinging a fly ball right field fairly
deep but mazara tracking it toward the
corner will make the catch that is a
good first inning for derek scuba he
filled up the strike zone miguel cabrera
leads off the tiger second another 2-2
and he got strike three by foul tip
jeffers hangs on second strikeout for
half
nothing soft
for miggy all hard stuff candelario he's
at second base with only one out and now
we see zach short for the first time
not administ another strikeout for half
his third swinging strikeout
to trevor larnak he and jake rogers on
the same page the 1-2 and he strikes out
larnach his first punch-out of the night
and starts the second a real good slider
here from tariq skubal and again it's
just all set up sets it up by throwing a
fastball right down the middle of the
plate the priest won that battle to two
strikes ahead one and two
strikes out jeffers
just blew it by him
two away
that speed it's going to be very
difficult for him to
catch up two and two to max kepler
no need for the shift because kepler
swings and misses three strikeouts in
the last four batters faced for tarik
skubal unto watch as they continue to
grow
another strikeout this one
in the high 90s just changing the eye
level
haas turns on one deep left field that
ball is
go home
two-run shot for eric haas and the
tigers have drawn first blood here in
minnesota you start seeing what happ's
trying to do and all those fastballs
that he's throwing
and the first time up
he was trying to get eric hoss to hit
that that inside fastball
right off the pole
and he came in and haas was waiting for
it he's retired the first 10 batters
he's faced with that mechanical
adjustment he's able to throw it down in
the strike zone then come right back
with that one and get a strikeout
that's five strikeouts for tarik skubal
he has been a strikeout machine this
year you know it's it's down and away
and all of a sudden he comes up and it's
hard to catch up to that the one two
broken bat sinking to left haas charges
and makes the grab he's done it with his
bat now he does it with his glove louie
castro nomar mazzara and jake rogers in
detroit's fifth inning
nice pick by donaldson from the seat of
his pants he throws him out
what a nice play by josh donaldson
go glover amazing get that kind of zip
on the ball from the seat of your pants
jeffers who went down swinging his first
timeout
a deep drive to left field
there goes the perfect game there goes
the no winner and there goes the shutout
number six for ryan jeffers sure
expecting a fastball he got one middle
of the plate in 96 but he had enough bat
speed turn on it with that awesome power
got out of here in a hurry
faces are still loaded with one out and
the light hitting short at the plate
he walked him here comes jonathan scope
and the tigers lead is back to two
oh my goodness
what an acrobatic double play to end the
ending couple of nice plays on that
double play polanco with the stop but
then simmons had to feel the low flip
yeah what great reactions i mean first
of all it hits j hap
and then polanco had the presence of
mind with his glove to just flip it up
there and there's simmons what a
remarkable double play and they're on
the corners now for trevor larnick
how about that
hitting one between candelario in the
line driving in polanco and it's three
to two that's using the whole field yeah
pitch out away and
trevor went that way with it miguel sano
leads off the home seventh 3-2 tigers
blasted for the scoreboard
tiger
15th
and just like that we're even 3-3 at
target field see where the catcher's
target was inside
and miguel takes that pitch away from
him and with his power hits the other
way kepler advances to third celestino
down to second so there's the first out
see if the infield plays in polanco
coming up
to the backstop and now here comes
kepler
i don't know how polanco didn't get hit
by it
and we've seen so many carobs from
behind home plate bounce right back the
whole plate
that one was headed for third base
tough pitch to hit
now a high fly to center
retreating to the bag of celestino
he'll head home here's the throw to the
plate not in time and the twins have a
lead of two
[Applause]
donaldson strikes out for the second
time tonight but the damage done for
minnesota
duffy coming out to pitch to the tigers
in the eighth inning two at night for
miguel cabrera and the one-two he struck
him out swinging a fastball at 93. ends
cabrera's at bat buck farmer is on to
work the bottom half of the eighth
against nelson cruz
third strike for the first out
one down in the eighth one and two
larnick
with a swing and a miss strike three two
down
taylor rogers coming in to try to pick
up the save seven of them in nine tries
three pitches two outs
and now willy castro
got it
and a very quick three-ounce save for
taylor rogers
and a very neat 5-3 win for the twins
certainly the best game i've seen the
twins play in quite some time what a
great combination